riverhead hold tight for one superhero
size Marvel event first its marbles
Captain America 75 heroic years oh look
back at the making of an American icon I
was trying to play it cool I was nervous
then you're under arrest the two-hour
premiere of marvel's agent carter
fantastic she's headed to Hollywood to
crack a chilling new case and maybe get
a punch all of our a few skulls maybe I
could do with a hobby it all starts
Tuesday eight seven central on ABC
hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
trailer for the captain america 75th
anniversary special and a bit of a TF
for agent carter which is starting next
week so just here's an explainer for
what is going on a couple of days ago i
posted a trailer for DC special it's
doing a big special for its movies after
the first episode of the flash on the
19th but that same night Marvel is doing
two hours of programming is doing an
hour long Captain America 75th
anniversary special and that's for like
all of Captain America from the Golden
Age comic books all the way to the MCU
movies then right after that agent
Carter season two is premiering if you
haven't watched agent Carter season one
it's usually only 8 episode so it's more
like a mini series all about the Peggy
Carter character so it's a Marvel show
done in period but it does connect to
the movies the big comic book movie
things that are going to be going on in
season 2 or the dark force which is an
idea from the Doctor Strange comics as
well as Madame masque most people
usually associate Peggy Carter with
Captain America just because they have
so much history she's going to be in
Captain America Civil War and I know
there's some spoilers for Peggy Carter
and civil war just please use spoiler
tags if you want to comment about that
but we're agent Carter season 1 had a
lot of scenes from the original Captain
America movie in it season 2 will time
or directly to what's going on with
Doctor Strange in the comics just
because this idea of dark force it's
basically like dark matter it's like
extra dimensional energy that appears in
the Doctor Strange comics that they
stumble upon in season 2 rewind to the
first Avengers movie remember how they
were trying to use the tesseract find a
way to harness its energy just because
it was this infinite source of power but
they couldn't figure it out as you can
expect messing with powers beyond your
comprehension always blows up in your
face in a spectacular way as it does
it's going to be a lot of fun but if
you've been reading the new invincible
Iron Man title Madame masque actually
kind of opens that art there's a whole
bunch of Madame asked in the first
couple of issues and dr. doom for that
batter but I mean I mean dr. doom is not
going to be an agent Carter season 2 but
even though agent Carter is a TV series
that's appearing on ABC it's a little
bit different from the way they make
agents of shield so agent Carter is
produced by Marvel Studios the same
entity that produces the film's Kevin
baggy himself actually sat in an editing
Bay and edited a couple episodes
agent Carter season one like that that's
how much care they're taking with a
series the reason it's only eight
episodes of series is because they try
to give it this more cinematic look
which requires more special effects and
because it's done in period so when they
film outside they have to use a lot of
special effects to make everything look
like late 1940s early 1950s so it just
it cost of a little bit more and they
take a little extra care so it's just
easier for them to do fewer episodes on
the same budget on the other side of
that coin agents of shield is actually
produced by ABC studios so it's like a
completely different group of people so
just in general agent Carter tends to
look a little bit shinier like you know
it's a little bit prettier than agents
of shield just because they spend a lot
more money on the effects mostly because
they have to but also because they want
to it totally goes without saying Hayley
Atwell is amazing as Peggy Carter and
she's probably my favorite female Marvel
character right now and like her more
than I like Black Widow mostly because
they haven't really given Black Widow a
major arc in the movies yet like she
hasn't had her solo movie it almost
feels like I've all the female
characters thus far they put on
pedestals Peggy Carter has gotten the
best treatment now Scarlett which is
kind of rising is like the new most
powerful female in the Marvel Universe
at least until Captain Marvel comes in
so that could all change down the road
just the way they're positioning Scarlet
Witch in captain america civil war makes
it sound like she's going to do
something amazingly terrible to everyone
here's what I'm advising next week
starting on Tuesday just because there's
so much Marvel and DC stuff happening
DVR everything all the DC stuff the
episode of the flash the DC specials for
the movies that's going to be on the CW
all the Marvel stuff is going to be
happening on ABC so as long as your DVR
everything you'll totally be safe I
recommend you watch the DC stuff first
just because they're throwing a little
more stuff into it and there's going to
be footage from the Wonder Woman movie
like the first trailer is going to drop
during that special then you can go and
watch the Marvel stuff I'm not expecting
new captain america civil war footage
but they might drop some if they do I'll
totally do a video for it like my first
videos next Tuesday are going to be
wonder woman trailer video then Suicide
Squad then captain america civil war
then my episode of the flash I mean it
really just depends on what new footage
they drop but I'm gonna be going crazy
trying to get everything done it's going
to be so amazing you guys have no idea
that's really the stuff I get excited
for when there's like ten awesome things
on the same night and it's like
oh my god i could do videos for all this
stuff usually there's like a big TV show
you guys don't see me making videos for
that's the reason because there's like
10 things on the same night and i just
don't have time for it but what i'm
going to do next is is it was a huge
Star Wars rebels season 2 trailer that
had a whole bunch of force awakens stuff
in it a whole bunch of classic stuff
princess Leia's coming on the show so
I'm going to do a video for that next be
sure to subscribe to get it why I guess
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn how captain america civil war
gets started and you can click here for
my doctor strange teaser video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you